here you are competing with Jimmy Kim
but I'm not I'm not competing Jimmy Carr
I'm not what is that Yahoo is CBS is
competing with NBC and ABC and TBS or
whoever it is you know Conan and Jimmy
Juan and Jimmy - yes I call right today
No all right both of them know who's
number one and number two in my heart
did you in fact write an email to Jimmy
Fallon and say hey I'm not interested in
the traditional feud no way to do email
we went out and had drinks oh you did
know we're friends like we've known I've
known for a long time really friends in
the sense that once you saw he's been
what what do you mean one of them
because CBS and NBC are locked in a
network battle but it's different for
them your career definitely depends on
beating the [ __ ] out of Jimmy Fallon I
disagree and I don't think finally know
what I'll say this I'm in the in
memoriam reel already okay look let me
ask you something how you gonna feel
they're gonna play sad music when I die
how you gonna feel when you're trying to
wait I'll be late in the real don't get
me wrong I'm not the job right I'm down
with like a really good editor mission
of like a producer you've never heard
any what the differences his people are
going to either steal a bit you felt you
did or they're going to get a guest that
you had booked and then now it's on
booked it's gonna [ __ ] happen ha ha
mr. religious it's gonna go right out
the window all about all that
Catholicism right out of economy doing
Santeria I'm gonna be killing chickens
we're gonna have a Google Doc that's
right that's right it's gonna be vicious
and don't kid yourself it is why
shouldn't I kid myself I'm a kid or a
kid yourself if you want if you must